merci façon à tout autre sujet après on
va parler théâtre ou plutôt
improvisation à théâtrale mardi a vu le
17ème championnat inter collèges de
match d'improvisation théâtrale c'était
attrape les élèves finalistes de quatre
collèges de saint quentin en yvelines se
sont affrontés dans la salle de la
mairie une compétition organisée par un
déclic théâtre est parrainée par de
nombreux artistes et humoristes comme il
sait tout bia qui a remis le prix à
l'équipe gagnante qui a mouillé lambert
et via mail pour ce reportage
je vous demande est là mais les gains qu
on lui doit la finale de la 17ème
compétition du ciq mythe de déclic
théâtre a réuni les élèves de quatre
collèges de saint quentin en yvelines
sur les planches de la merise le 31 mai
l'événement permet aux collégiens
finalistes de se familiariser avec le
public dans une véritable salle comme
des professionnels moi j'étais
impressionné ce soir par le plaisir des
joueurs
et laquelle il la qualité de lait coûte
entre eux pendant près de deux heures
les équipes s'affrontent sur des matchs
d'improvisation
le thème est donné par l'arbitré les
élèves en seulement quelques secondes
pour préparer leur show
un exercice par lequel sont passés de
nombreux artistes comme jamel debbouze
sophia aram ou encore issa doumbia qui
était présent mardi pour remettre le
premier prix
public sait quelque chose
y en a qui sont en fonte patinoire mais
au fur à mesure des départs on les voit
et c'est ça qui est mon présent dans
cette compétition les collèges alexandre
dumas de maurepas gustave courbet le
village pour la ville de trappes ainsi
qu'albert einstein de magny les hameaux
a donné mon
prix les votes du public fait à main
levée le nom des grands gagnants tombe
et c'est le collège albert einstein de
magny les hameaux qui sort vainqueur de
cette 17e édition la victoire voilà
c'est ce qu'on va surtout retenir le
collège einstein je pense à
toi non je rigole bien évidemment non
franchement c'est une formidable
formidable aventure c'était vraiment
sympa les gens sont super sympas les
autres joueurs sont super sympas moi
c'était mon premier side 8 et
franchement je regrette pas parce que
c'était vraiment une super expérience et
de rencontrer d'autres équipes c'est
juste juste magique comme annie sapé
comme annie sapé comme manu